[SPEAKER_04]: Early in the morning, between the 2nd and 3rd of Wealsun, the party leaves the doorway, the northern exit to the barracks, and into the night.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so you guys slip that into the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: Who goes first?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll take Lee, he goes behind me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Merrick goes into, out of the wall, and do you want to run towards the palm tree forest, right there?
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to stay on the edge of the palm tree forest, but enough where I can see the coastline as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you want to go around this way, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Kind of like totally far away from where the barracks are, so you're completely unseen from these cliffs.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you run to here, and then start going around that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Stealthing, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, roll your stealth.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six, plus five, eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so he runs off into the darkness.
[SPEAKER_04]: The light of the moon, however, shows you to him.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's nothing for it though.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of you kind of have to follow him this way and hope that being
[SPEAKER_04]: A thousand feet from the guards on the walls.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hand-dressed as hobgoblins that maybe... Well, hobgoblins sleeping in the barracks would be very strange.
[SPEAKER_04]: But whatever, it's probably not something they'll be able to see at this distance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do they have dark men?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, how far do you want to let Merrick go before you follow up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I want to be within.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably 30 feet of him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you run out 30 feet, you follow after that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's next?
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul, you follow 30 feet after?
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul's the green pawn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Basically, you... Don't leave Jude on the back end.
[SPEAKER_05]: You take off...
[SPEAKER_01]: I was just going to say, I'd rather not be on the back end.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, where is Jude?
[SPEAKER_04]: It goes...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'd be, like, second to last.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you're last, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, basically, you make it to there, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: And stop by the coast, looking over the...
[SPEAKER_04]: Ledge down to the beach below.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're high above the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: And actually on this side the waves come up and the coastline is incredibly watery.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I know any rumor of where these entrances could be?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or have any idea where it most likely is?
[SPEAKER_04]: The rumor is they're on this side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Far above the rock there.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I think what really catches your eye is that there is a ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: In the water, right there, lit up with lanterns.
[SPEAKER_04]: A ship that is foreign.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not a Kosair.
[SPEAKER_04]: And actually, it doesn't even look like a Toli ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's stocked off of the helm maybe 300 feet, 400 feet, and there are people, a lot of people walking it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge comes up next to you as you stare down at the ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you thinking?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm thinking possibly... Do I recommend any flags, any sales, anything?
[SPEAKER_05]: There is no flag.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll an insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: 22.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've seen ships like this before.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're a new kind of vessel that's created by the Onwallian traders.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very good cargo ships.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very fast.
[SPEAKER_04]: And their sails are very innovative.
[SPEAKER_04]: They can actually get speeds faster than Cosaire's, which is strange.
[SPEAKER_03]: When I move up, do I recognize them?
[SPEAKER_04]: So, Paul, you come up next to Gouge and Merrick, and they're looking down at this craft.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where is this ship?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anchor up there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can see it from where you are, but it's like basically stationed right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this, do I recognize, like is this one of our ships?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hey, it's one of these new ships that I've seen that it's a new type of animation that's very fast.
[SPEAKER_03]: I came out of... Who makes this ship?
[SPEAKER_03]: Onwal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are they from?
[SPEAKER_01]: Onwallian traders.
[SPEAKER_01]: From Onwal, which is across the other side of the ocean.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So could this...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it could just be a trade ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have no idea what's going on, and this is a huge trade run.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is tied to this kind of situation.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's a possibility, but I think we've got to take it as a fact.
[SPEAKER_05]: How far off is it from the shore?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's 400 feet away from the helm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of a sudden, you see a ship, a smaller vessel, kind of a little skiff, come from nowhere and start sailing towards the ship off the coast.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mark that spot where it comes from, nowhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mark it for your...
[SPEAKER_00]: Search.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you see how the coastline curves?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are the rest of us up there yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, you guys are up here.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys are all hiding right here, looking at this vessel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you mean fog?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no fog.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there fog tonight?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's as if he just came out of the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously that's where our tunnel is.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merrick, have you searched that part of that island before?
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know that area?
[SPEAKER_02]: I should be familiar with the back end, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is this something I would recognize going on around that?
[SPEAKER_04]: So you've seen the rocks there and the navigation into that area, there are a lot of rocks on that thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to know what you're doing to be able to pilot in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even a small ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they've been here before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I recognize the small ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything that I would have seen coming out of the back of it?
[SPEAKER_02]: It actually looks like a...
[SPEAKER_04]: Monmurg is a smuggler ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: A small skiff that is very good in the oceans around here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You wouldn't want to take it on the high seas, but in the bay of Jerley Bay or around the Houle River, these things go all over the place.
[SPEAKER_04]: They smuggle, raid goods.
[SPEAKER_04]: They don't raid very much.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not too many people can be there, but they're kind of like the workhorses.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're like mail ships, stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can assume that the secret passage has been compromised.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't want to make this clear, but I didn't want to say that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I took off the silver mask I have on and put it on the darker shadow mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: The shadow mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanted to do that before.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not part of all of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right, that's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_03]: But he could be set up by one of the other princes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, or be in a compromised position, though he has to.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: My gut's telling me that this is a political thing, with the back end of it, you know, because we know something possibly political is going on, but the ship coming out, they might be in, you know, probably, because we put the Hobbes album...
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, what would they be smuggling out?
[SPEAKER_03]: Just because it's a smuggler isn't a smuggler.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: What would they be smuggling out?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or have they been bringing things in?
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, or that's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_03]: They could be reinforcing more troops.
[SPEAKER_06]: Does the ship look loaded now or does it look unloaded now?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks low in the water.
[SPEAKER_06]: Very loaded.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're taking something out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Take it to them and sending it out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I don't think...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if we want to get involved with finding what that is versus getting to the guy who decided to go right to the head of it to see what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if I agree with that.
[SPEAKER_03]: If they're transporting something out, then it was important enough for them to come here and tell it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't understand ships, so I don't understand how low in the water, and if you're not talking about them taking troops off.
[SPEAKER_03]: If it's not loaded with troops, then it's loaded with something else.
[SPEAKER_03]: And if they're taking something out, remember, we just came here and forced.
[SPEAKER_03]: They know that there's 150 garrison.
[SPEAKER_03]: They probably know that there's like the 30 of you and the 20 of us.
[SPEAKER_03]: They know that they've lost people.
[SPEAKER_03]: They know that they're almost maybe at a stalemate, other than that they hold a defensive.
[SPEAKER_03]: But they also know they're close to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I mean, we can be reinforced in like a day or two is at most.
[SPEAKER_03]: So what I'm almost wondering is if we need to adjust on the fly and take the ship.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think they're snuggling stuff and supplies that are meant for Monmurg and loading stuff up and giving it to these guys who are sailing back there, cutting us off.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's just where I'm going with it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, so you think supplies initially got through the blockade and are...
[SPEAKER_03]: He's with them and they're taking stuff and they're getting it together and going.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you think it might be just as simple as draining of supplies from the owner?
[SPEAKER_05]: Which would hurt Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to move forward on the coastline, just me, in the rocks, and try to get a better inspection of what's going on stealthily.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just going to go solo and see what's up.
[SPEAKER_02]: If there's any compromise, I can throw a fog cloud out.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can just get back and do a different plan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you guys want to stay here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to move up to a better place right to here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do all of you want to go to there?
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to be somewhere where we've got good cover.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I want to get closer.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you can move to here without being seen.
[SPEAKER_04]: It would give you a very good advantage on what the ship was doing.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then the next thing would be able to climb the thing to get up to the... A little bit of the bluff.
[SPEAKER_04]: To get up to the wall?
[SPEAKER_04]: To the wall if you wanted to.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this position here you know would be the best.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's our time limit before they start attacking?
[SPEAKER_04]: We've probably got maybe five minutes?
[SPEAKER_04]: You've got another 15 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you guys go to the wall up there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do want to inspect down there and see what's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge, do you want to come or do you want me to go solo?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, he was saying moving ahead is moving into a better position for the wall and for observation of the ships.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's get to that point and then take a look and see if you need to go further.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the six of you move around the forest and the coastline to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And in that time, the ship, the little smuggler ship, gets to the boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they start unloading.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys are here right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they're unloading barrels about this big.
[SPEAKER_02]: A barrel I would have seen back at Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything familiar with my time on the CC?
[SPEAKER_04]: They look like brandy kegs.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
Interesting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what do we want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we want to go over the wall or do we want to take these caves?
[SPEAKER_04]: In this position where you're at, with the boat just for a freeway, you see that there are hobgoblins down there unloading.
[SPEAKER_04]: You do, however, notice a very strange looking character.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got shock white hair.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very pale.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is this on the ship that we see?
[SPEAKER_04]: This is on the ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he's standing there as other people command.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's a Toli.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no doubt.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's a what?
[SPEAKER_04]: A Toli.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's from Port Toli.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's Suel.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not a non-Wallian traitor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: The shocking white hair would be Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, Gouge, it looks a lot like one of those four people you slaughtered on the docks about a month ago with that frog wizard.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it says Lord Jamis expected.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Lord told he's good.
[SPEAKER_03]: This skiff will be coming back, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: In all likelihood.
[SPEAKER_06]: Unless they got everything they wanted out of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Back and forth loading.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're just starting unloading.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: So this is a good opportunity.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we're going to go to the skiff, we're going to go now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or we could take the skiff and ride it back.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, it's got a full ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are we thinking of going onto the ship?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, well, I mean, I don't know how, I mean, other than swimming out to the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was thinking if the skiff is coming back, should we waylay the skiff?
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll an insight check.
[SPEAKER_03]: And ride the skiff in.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long does it take us to get to those rocks?
[SPEAKER_04]: 18.
[SPEAKER_04]: How would you get down to the rocks?
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no beach.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's nowhere to walk.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to have a boat to even find it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean... Oh, so you have to go in on a boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is a 300-foot drop.
[SPEAKER_04]: Down to the ocean.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, where are we guessing the cave entrance is, or are we thinking that's where the skip's coming from?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can send my homoculi out to start looking.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, if you throw it over and it goes down there, is it going to come back?
[SPEAKER_04]: I control it.
[SPEAKER_04]: It won't come back though, it'll glide down.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was going to say it'll glide down, but...
[SPEAKER_04]: It'll be down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: It'll have to climb back.
[SPEAKER_03]: You wouldn't get it for the rest of tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so I think I was worried about the fact that if this is a secret smuggler's cave, there's probably only interest on a water path.
[SPEAKER_03]: Probably the cliff is shaped in such a way that we're not going to be able to just get down there on feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we would either be trying to position ourselves to waylay and jump on the skiff as it was coming back, and we would... You guys hear a shout.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's take the castle.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then all of a sudden,
[SPEAKER_04]: Yells from up on the barracks.
[SPEAKER_04]: And up here, you see men, or hobgoblins, run this way to that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're moving on the front gate.
[SPEAKER_04]: What does the Toli guy do?
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy down here?
[SPEAKER_04]: He's loading the boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: He looks up, but that's about all he does.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get in.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think we probably should stick with Cass.
[SPEAKER_00]: I said, um...
[SPEAKER_05]: It's gonna be easier for me to climb then, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: There's an entrance that's on this side of the castle over here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Steve told us if we can get over to this, there's a door that we could probably get in through.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys aren't getting levitated by Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can climb up, you would have to climb up the 50 foot wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: And what Steve said is that there is a, the tower, there's an entrance to the tower from the walls.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you have to get up the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I can get one of you up the wall, probably you, and if you can take a rope and just throw it over one of the cremulations or two ropes that are already prepared.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you can get somebody up the wall, I'd appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm the biggest dude here and I...
[SPEAKER_05]: If you want to take two of us up, you can...
[SPEAKER_05]: I can't take two.
[SPEAKER_05]: You throw one up and I'll climb.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, you're pretty lith, so I can take you up?
[SPEAKER_03]: That'd be a lot better than me climbing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can hold the rope for anybody that wants to get up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to keep my eyes on the coast, watching what the ship's doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Plus, if there's anybody up there...
[SPEAKER_05]: I wish he was down below watching Jude sweat trying to levitate that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, Jude's got a good location.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, I'll uptake you, but like, why don't you take, like, let's give him two ropes with, like, you know, that are kind of pre-prepared.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I have a rope.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so first off, you guys scramble up the hill.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that sounds nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dun-dun-dun.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have a little remote under the table?
[SPEAKER_04]: The AC goes on and it makes the light.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to get electric.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's just a bump.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, you guys, do you want to wait until men quit coming out of this thing?
[SPEAKER_04]: I will try to stealth.
[SPEAKER_05]: That direction and say, wait, as those guys are running, I'm gonna just try to sell through?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you, as they run, are the rest of you gonna wait where you're at?
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys gotta keep in cover.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I mean, we want to stay hidden and like discreet, you know, cloaks over us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get the ropes ready.
[SPEAKER_03]: Perhaps way down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm worried about ropes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, and so you run the, I would say, 100 feet to the wall, and you're selfing, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Row yourself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_05]: 13 plus 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Gouge makes it to the wall, and you guys are sitting there.
[SPEAKER_04]: It takes him maybe 40 seconds to run at the wall, but he gets up against it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're still watching the boat?
[SPEAKER_04]: They're just loading.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like they're not even, they don't even notice what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna stealth up with Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run next.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you guys doing?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm waiting for... Are you watching the walls?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm counting the guys that are going by.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm counting to get an idea of how many guys are going by.
[SPEAKER_01]: 30 or 40.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you've got a crossbow, keep it ready if you have to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you have your crossbow out and you're watching?
[SPEAKER_03]: Anybody that pauses and looks over, if they're going to look down and spy him, you need to assassinate them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you sneak up next to Gouge, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Add advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then roll again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten plus five?
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick runs up next to Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Both of them are at the base of the wall and where do you want to be at the base of the wall?
[SPEAKER_04]: The one right next to the tower or this side?
[SPEAKER_05]: I want to stay on the south side.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we were here and I'm on the wall.
[SPEAKER_05]: And all this shit's gonna happen out front here.
[SPEAKER_05]: And they're loading down there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I wanna be back behind right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, like almost right at that seam, like where the big base tower joins in that smaller wall.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, right behind that too.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Almost like climb up the base tower, not the smaller wall itself, like the curtain wall, but that base tower, but then where you can just hook around the edge with a float or something like that and jump onto that if you wanted.
[SPEAKER_03]: But if there's more people running, we can stay on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep up and I can probably hear before I go over.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, the two of you are at the base of the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: The rest of you, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to go up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get a bow out.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have your bow ready and you start climbing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who's next to moving?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do the rest of you guys do?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll run up to the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Tyrus goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, is Tyrus like a...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's wearing a breastplate, but yeah, he is kind of like that.
I'm big.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, can't we?
[SPEAKER_00]: We didn't levitate, I'm not?
[SPEAKER_03]: We've got to get to the base of the ball.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't just levitate people.
[SPEAKER_06]: Greatest to be her, can you hear us, style?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would be going at it, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: I get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so roll stealth at advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus...
[SPEAKER_06]: Zero.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or is it plus two?
[SPEAKER_06]: Negative two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus two, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go again.
[SPEAKER_01]: 18 plus two, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's actually very quiet.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's sneakier than me.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's off.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, a big guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is four hours later.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rolling like Croc.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Gouge, you're moving up while he runs up, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: In the time it takes Tyrus to get to where the wall is, he's moving so it's 100 feet, you climb, roll your athletics check,
[SPEAKER_05]: Thirteen, altogether.
[SPEAKER_04]: When he is twenty feet from the wall, you are right at the top of it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're up there.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm going to hold and just look down to see that he's going and listen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so Tyrus gets up next to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who's next?
[SPEAKER_04]: The three of you are back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which ones are up?
[SPEAKER_04]: No one's up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge is at the top of the wall, these two are at the base.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, is he actually climbing up to the top?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, then I gotta go.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll go next.
[SPEAKER_02]: Remember, we gotta protect the kid, too.
[SPEAKER_05]: I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: You run.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm older than you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, do you want me to roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kid in.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, you're masked and stuff.
[SPEAKER_05]: You gotta protect your prince.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just because I'm a prince, you know?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you can listen, do a perception, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Perception I get.
[SPEAKER_04]: 22.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear the clink of a blade against somebody's leg, armored leg.
[SPEAKER_04]: Somebody's close over that wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want me to roll?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I've got a plus seven?
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen plus seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: And it's an advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven plus seven, so 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Jude runs up.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: Anything?
[SPEAKER_05]: Did I know it sounded like walking like a sword against the thing or somebody maybe grabbing the scabbard?
[SPEAKER_01]: It could be walking, but not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't sound like somebody's moving around.
[SPEAKER_04]: It sounded like somebody just patted their leg or something and made that.
[SPEAKER_04]: It was like a scabbard against something like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to try to peek.
[SPEAKER_05]: Self.
[SPEAKER_05]: Am I level three now?
[SPEAKER_05]: You are.
[SPEAKER_05]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You look up.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see a hobgoblin right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, guarding the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: The door is open.
[SPEAKER_04]: No other hobgoblins you see.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are hobgoblins over there, maybe 100 feet away on the far side with crossbows firing down on the men.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear yelling over there.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a lot of noise.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: While it's all going around, I'm going to try to go over and sneak and take them out.
[SPEAKER_05]: But they've got to do what they've got to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to motion for one of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't care which one.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run across 100 feet towards them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to ready a spell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh!
[SPEAKER_01]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you got another roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: So wait, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: I said I was gonna ready a spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six total?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I said I was gonna ready a spell.
[SPEAKER_03]: The spell is darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, basically, Folsom runs out and trips.
[SPEAKER_01]: He falls on it and starts running again.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's 30 feet out.
[SPEAKER_04]: You dug down, the hobgoblin turns.
[SPEAKER_04]: As that happens, it starts going over that direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I see the hobgoblin?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's up on the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Gouge, you're basically hanging down there right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: All we've got left is you to get to the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'll go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, you have a spell ready?
[SPEAKER_01]: I cast Darkness.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I cast it on him?
[SPEAKER_03]: The one who just bit the dust?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if you cast it on him, it's gonna be a dark thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would it stay on him?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's gotta be an area.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he's already up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, let me see that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, you can cast darkness on somebody.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can cast it on somebody, yes, and it will move with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, you can do that, but he won't be able to see it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, shit, that's right.
Make it work.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not deafness at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could you cast?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like, am I deaf?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know, I don't do anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you cast darkness on top?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, maybe the gouge is right there on the edge of the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I just hold it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I hold it in readiness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so it's ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom is running, but you're just hanging out?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, if I'm basically...
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna try to hide in Shadow because I'm on the side of the wall, but...
[SPEAKER_05]: I want to hop out and attack this guy when he's close enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're basically ready to attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so... Paul, Veros, and Folsom, you're still running towards the wall, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want me to roll stealth?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll stealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not missed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you're right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or... Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: You're hanging out, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And what was your stealth roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: The last one?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it was a 13 plus 7.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a 13 plus 7, 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear him moving closer.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you hear the cock of a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: You roll a niche.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You run towards the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do anything else with your action or dash?
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to dash and get to the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're just running.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, you're... Paul actually is right next to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a 30 feet behind him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: This hobgoblin comes right here with his crossbow, and he's like, you can tell he's got a target.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have your ready action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hey, ready?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm a hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like, nothing to see here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're off.
[SPEAKER_05]: So what is my best possibility from this position?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I hold and just take a dagger attack?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I jump to get on him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Or can I try to grab and pull?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know how close I am or what I physically can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're five feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to grapple him, you can grapple him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which means he won't be able to shoot and you can try to climb up there.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can attack now and wait till next round to move because you don't have a move right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or you can just wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: What can I attack with?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can you attack with a bad dagger or can I attack with my scimitar?
[SPEAKER_05]: You can attack with your scimitar.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll attack with my scimitar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do I get...
[SPEAKER_05]: So he's not in combat yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can assassinate if you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go for an assassination attempt.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you attack with advantage because he's surprised.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then what's the next roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: Advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14 plus what?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is that 14 total?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that's a 14 roll plus your attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, my attack bonus is plus 4.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, more than that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, don't forget to get your proficiency as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, yes, yes, yes, hold on.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've got two, I've got two with the cutlass, making it 16.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: See that plus seven with the cutlass?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you see the plus seven with the cutlass?
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus 9.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's your attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_04]: 9 plus 14 is 23.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that hits his AC of 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you stab him with your cutlass.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to use your sneak attack on this?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because it's an assassinate, you'll automatically do a crit, which means your cut list is just one die six, just two die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your sneak attack do?
[SPEAKER_01]: And the sneak attack is plus three die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's six die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So all told, it's eight die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, two?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two is your cut list, and then six more is the sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_06]: Holy shnikes.
[SPEAKER_06]: So how many?
[SPEAKER_06]: Eight total.
[SPEAKER_05]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was a lot of ones there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Seven, twelve, fourteen, eighteen, twenty-one, twenty-two, twenty-four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-four plus your six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-eight.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thirty, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he comes up, and he's cocking his crossbow, and then you stab him in the heart.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, let's see which way he falls.
[SPEAKER_04]: Luckily, he falls backwards.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And not only to you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically you stab this guy, he falls backwards without a noise.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll an inch.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who?
[SPEAKER_01]: You.
Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're going to say all you guys are next after Gouge.
[SPEAKER_05]: So Gouge, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: You're right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to scout looking both ways to see if there's any other men up here.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you pop your head up?
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't see any men here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see a lot of them over there, like 40 or 50 over there firing down, but there's nobody in this area right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's no door on the tower on this side, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: There's a door right there, and it's open.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to wave down.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And now, do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm going to come up and over.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to come over just to the side of that door and try to... One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can come right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can hold an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to try to hide in shadows holding there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you want to use your bonus action to do a hide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus your stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is 720.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're hiding right there and you have an action still.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're gonna just ready the action.
[SPEAKER_04]: If anybody comes out the door, you slash them?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just gonna have my dagger and my scimitar out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're just standing there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just watching.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next person.
[SPEAKER_03]: I levitate his ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got the rope.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ready to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you cast Levitate.
[SPEAKER_01]: First level, second level spell slot.
[SPEAKER_03]: I did.
[SPEAKER_03]: I marked it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You move 20 feet up in the air.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is creepy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do the rest of you want to wait, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Palmer Bear, I want you to start going up, and I'm going to take back with Folsom, because he clearly needs some help.
[SPEAKER_02]: A little nervous right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Paul, you start climbing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Paul starts climbing at the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're just hanging out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Levitating.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, I can't do more than 20 feet around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, do you guys want to just wait for Tyrus to be levitated up?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think...
[SPEAKER_02]: You should go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul's going to keep climbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, Paul is climbing 15 feet per turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going up 20 feet per turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge, you're just sitting here, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, you're nothing.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're just basically waiting.
[SPEAKER_04]: So 18, 20 seconds go by.
[SPEAKER_04]: You come up to the top of the wall and step off to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tied the rope off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he even see me?
[SPEAKER_01]: He sees you right there.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you hook the rope off?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm gonna stand there like a hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're basically like a hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're on your knees though, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: They could be big.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're big guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they're like, okay, they're bigger than...
[SPEAKER_00]: Regular goblins, but they're not like six foot.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're big!
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not as big as bugbears.
[SPEAKER_00]: They could be six foot.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's obviously not the runt of the litter.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you gotta think, because we took out a hobgoblin that fits his armor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, that's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Round up for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to see something, actually.
[SPEAKER_05]: Where's the door supposed to go?
[SPEAKER_05]: I remember.
[SPEAKER_05]: Where's what?
[SPEAKER_05]: So you're standing on the deck.
[SPEAKER_05]: Where's that door supposed to go?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm on the back side of this tower, so that's a door going into here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sir, we think it gets us into this area?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're not right here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Aidy, real quick.
[SPEAKER_06]: Are we to the front of this tower, or are we on the back side of this tower?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, you're right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that door goes into the big area, not the tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we are right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're on the south, westerly part.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I think the door goes into the tall tower, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Doesn't that door go into the tall tower?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Paul, you get up to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have two of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rug comes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys want to start climbing up it?
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We and him will start climbing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to levitate yourself up?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll climb.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get me in the shadow where I'm not seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you're right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This next round, these guys are climbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you want to run to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Make sure he gets up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get me next to Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run to there and you want to hide with your bonus action and ready your crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your stealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you basically sit next to Gouge and watch the hobgoblins over there fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jude, you go up, I'll go left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom's going up for sure, then you go, and then I'll take the rear.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's two ropes, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, there's one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then I'm watching them to make sure they don't fall or need help or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, twenty seconds later, Folsom comes up and comes over the edge and lands there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is your dex, by the way?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you're fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, and where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to stand next to Tyrus, or do you want to run over to these guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be with Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll put you in here, and I'll turn him around so he's watching the other way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Watching your back?
[SPEAKER_06]: Watching my back, because I'm watching the guys over the edge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I'll go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude comes up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude comes up.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys still have not been noticed.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just squat down in the shadows.
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to stealth?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you come to here and squat?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, roll yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fifteen plus seven.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then Merrick, you come up?
[SPEAKER_01]: They're coming up.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen seconds later, Merrick is right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys have just been sitting here for about 45 seconds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick gets up on the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put that patch on me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: You don't know anything about this place either.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's only the sanctuary.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we're trying to get to him, but he's down below.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so I know exactly where we're at.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so where does this door lead?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, the door goes into the tower, and the sanctuary is that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a great hole where there are fortifications.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then at the end of it, there's another door that leads to a place where there's a guard room and the sanctuaries on the other side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Guys, I think we should get up that tower also.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's going to get us out of vision of these 40, whatever's going on here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's get in this tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, take the rope off.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to proceed in with stealth.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I'm going to take this body and I'm going to
[SPEAKER_06]: Picture it over the wall.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think it's a good idea.
[SPEAKER_06]: Get rid of the body.
[SPEAKER_06]: No disagreement.
[SPEAKER_03]: As he's lifting off the body, I search.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm looking for any keys, any bags of gold.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you got some keys.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got keys, and I got an insignia.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'll pick up this crossbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a gel fan.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, I don't do the language.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's so much the gel fan.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you go ahead and write a suicide note?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know where it is.
I don't know where it is.
I don't know where it is at all.
I kind of don't think it would.
[SPEAKER_00]: So which way are we headed?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that one of those coins?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, where does the pack I got?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's interesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got online.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got one that's like a memento mori.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like a skull.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is that two-sided dice?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, it's not just a set of dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like a coin.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's circular.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's kind of like one of these.
[SPEAKER_03]: They'll make like a steel coin.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's on your coin?
[SPEAKER_03]: It shows a skull.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's that translate to?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's basically like all life is fleeting.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, so Gouge, you look into the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see a hobgoblin right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Guardian there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Doors open.
[SPEAKER_05]: I reach around.
[SPEAKER_05]: To Paul.
[SPEAKER_05]: Slip back with him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Take a shot.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's a hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wait a minute.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can distract him if you shoot around me.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I want him to take a stealthy shot right there, unseen.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's got his crossbow loaded.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can probably drop him.
[SPEAKER_05]: And if not, I'm rushing him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so I go to where he sits, and what do I see?
[SPEAKER_04]: You transfer places, look around the corner, and you see a hobgoblins sitting right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'll make the shot.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you point your bow with advantage because you're surprising him, and do you want to assassinate?
[SPEAKER_04]: I can do that with a crossbow, can I?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you backstab with a crossbow?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can sneak attack when you have advantage, so you can.
[SPEAKER_04]: At advantage, you roll 2 die 20 to hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16 is the highest, plus what?
[SPEAKER_04]: For the light crossbows, plus 6, that's 22.
[SPEAKER_04]: 22?
[SPEAKER_04]: That hits?
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to do a sneak attack?
[SPEAKER_04]: That's 2-die-6?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: The short crossbows, 1-die-8, so it's 2-die-8 plus 4-die-6.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because 2-die-6 is 1-die-8.
[SPEAKER_04]: 2-die-8.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, 2-die-8.
[SPEAKER_04]: 4-die-8.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's an eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I need?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four die six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't roll like Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's an eight, I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight, five, one, two-eighths.
[SPEAKER_05]: So that's sixteen, seventeen, eighteen, twenty-three, twenty-four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-four plus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-four plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: So twenty-eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hit him.
[SPEAKER_04]: You like the neck shots.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hit him in the neck and he falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: You elbow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Good job.
[SPEAKER_01]: Quiet, quiet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good job.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You move in?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look around.
[SPEAKER_04]: Stairs going down here.
[SPEAKER_04]: A door here.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's open.
[SPEAKER_04]: A dead hobgoblin here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't see anybody in here.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's torches on the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna go in.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bring up the keys.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merrick knows where we need to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so let's see your characters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's who?
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick, Gouge, there's Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just move me somewhere in the middle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put me right behind Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're here now.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's your character?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm the green pawn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're the green pawn?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's this?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is that the four-sided that makes music?
[SPEAKER_05]: They're there.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's Folsom.
[SPEAKER_05]: Folsom and Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we'll do you first.
[SPEAKER_04]: You run in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where do you want to be?
[SPEAKER_04]: Put me on that left wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four, five, six to there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you got your crossbow?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want to ready your action?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to dash or do you want to have an action ready?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll just dash into the corner.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to dash in the middle of the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: To there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll move and dash and just post up it right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or do you want to be here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just up against the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going in right next to Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have long strike?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not active.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys enter the room.
[SPEAKER_06]: What do you want to do now?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, where do we need to go?
[SPEAKER_06]: Shut that door behind us.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can it lock?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I'll shut the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can bar it if you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tyrus, you're standing at the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I mean, if I bar this door, there's...
[SPEAKER_06]: Nobody's going to come behind us.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'd rather be in front where I can take a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you run into here and look at the body?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got a bag of coins.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got hobgoblin weapons.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scalemail.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So Tyrus, you move there?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: A bolt out of his neck if you can.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I pull it out?
[SPEAKER_00]: I give it back to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you pull it out, you can give it back later.
[SPEAKER_06]: So where do we got to go from here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there anything, a stairway up or is it just down?
[SPEAKER_03]: This stairway goes down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there any stairway up?
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't see one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's something around that corner over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what's my knowledge?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a stairway over here that goes to the top of the tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: This stairway goes down to the inner port of locations, the level below.
[SPEAKER_04]: The inner sanctum is that way through this doorway, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the safe room we're talking about.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably going to be heavily guarded.
[SPEAKER_01]: The safe room is where
[SPEAKER_04]: Fairwind might be if he's holed up.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't know if he's there or not, but if he's safe and protected, he could have been a last stand there, and it would be hard for people to get to him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I say... You guys want to take sanctum?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that might be the best option.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, let's go across here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pinning ourselves inside, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll leave the way.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to go first.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I'll go first because if I'm going to take a bullet, it's going to be me.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll go first.
[SPEAKER_05]: I want to stealth up.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can stealth up, too.
[SPEAKER_05]: Open your door.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's open.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I also know the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know which ways to look going up, so I feel like I should leave the way here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You come in right behind me.
[SPEAKER_03]: How about we crack open the door and see what's on the other side?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we look through and see the next room?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just gonna look, that's the big question.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going up there right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three, four, five, six, you come to here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge behind you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm behind them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what about you two?
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys just waiting?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna just position myself here.
[SPEAKER_03]: If for any chance anybody comes up, I'll just pull them away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Folsom, you're just kind of sitting there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're crouching down, watching Mark and Gouge do their thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You look down at the fortification of where this is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now this room has columns that hold up the ceiling every 20-25 feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're hobgoblins stationed at these places.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically looking out at the fortification.
[SPEAKER_01]: On guard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Looking out windows?
[SPEAKER_01]: With arrow slits.
[SPEAKER_01]: Looking that direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are arrow slits in this direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell that this is like the secondary defense.
[SPEAKER_01]: People can make the wall, they go.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there are like, I would say at least 20 hobgoblins you see in the room looking out those arrow slits.
[SPEAKER_01]: And none on this side.
[SPEAKER_01]: None on that side.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're all there watching this happen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I don't see it, so I can't say anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can relay the information back to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you see?
[SPEAKER_06]: What do you see?
[SPEAKER_06]: I just go... What's up, like 20?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I go... 20?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, let's just march in formation.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, we're hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going to march along this wall in formation.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to put us between... because if we get caught... Is this five feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: Each one of these is five feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, nobody here just starts right here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it end?
[SPEAKER_01]: They keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: This hall keeps going.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's over here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't see the end or we can't?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are torches, but it's nighttime, so we estimate about 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can see that in the torchlight.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: There could be darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: There could be people in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_03]: I whispered a Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't whisper, we gotta get it on tape.
[SPEAKER_01]: He whispers to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can cast Darkness, and as long as we stay within the sphere, we can use the wall as a reference so that we're not lost, as long as there's no obstacles along this back wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can't see.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's why we use the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can't see out of darkness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to mention, darkness isn't like invisibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just a black cloud.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right, that they can't see into.
[SPEAKER_00]: So their hobgoblins are gonna turn around and be like,
[SPEAKER_00]: What the...?
[SPEAKER_00]: Only if Ryan slips.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you guys want to act like a group of hobgoblins and try to march behind?
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to use this...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we should... To who?
[SPEAKER_00]: Guys, I think it's going to be good for the... Guys, I have a negative two charisma.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, he means like, yeah, but that might be a plus for hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, a sneak attack's gonna take out one or two and they're all gonna know we're there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we're better off pretending we belong there and let's just start marching in like we own the place.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, let's just do like a light jog like we're moving, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_03]: The front's being attacked.
[SPEAKER_03]: We could move like we're in a hustle.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if anybody's got shields.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe keep the shields up?
[SPEAKER_03]: I definitely have shields.
[SPEAKER_03]: Start marching in.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who leads?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna lead.
[SPEAKER_01]: Big guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's in front of me.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have a patch.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he's huge, so he's gonna look like he's in charge.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, they're gonna look into the collar.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I grabbed Merrick, plus I'm gonna have my shield.
[SPEAKER_03]: So is this you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's do...
[SPEAKER_03]: Whichever we do, I'm going to be on the opposite side, kinda like...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't wanna be seen by the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So, it goes Tyrus, and then Jude is like the little guy... Then put me...
[SPEAKER_05]: And put Folsom on the other side of me with this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if it matters in terms of running, but can I pick up the hobgoblins' weapon to look more hobgobly?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, Merrick, I'll take back, and then...
[SPEAKER_01]: That's Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you going to be going up the rear too?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we have to, if this fails early on, to either A, get back to this door, or B, make it to the other one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you guys just start marching down the altar.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're in like a light jog.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I got that crossbow and I got my shield up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys start marching down, alright?
[SPEAKER_01]: Anybody speak hobgoblins?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, just do grublins.
[SPEAKER_05]: I bet you the elf does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, but I do speak Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you start marching down here, and Tyrus, this guy turns around and looks at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't make eye contact.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to signal, or do you want to do anything?
[SPEAKER_06]: Point in the direction he's supposed to be looking.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a performance check.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I do have performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: DC 10.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, a 10, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to roll a 20 and get better than a 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus 3 to performance.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was a little weird, but you guys keep moving.
[SPEAKER_04]: You keep marching down, and yes, it's 20 hobgoblins, and you march down.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are weapon racks in between these columns, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should we move them all up?
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys march down 150 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's 20 from here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Past the back of these hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you begin to approach the end of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul!
[SPEAKER_01]: All my ADHD got better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, what are they looking for?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you get behind me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude, you just made it by one point.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think I'm kind of intimidating.
[SPEAKER_06]: That gave me the plus three.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, it's that extra size that you got.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you're just all, and he's all.
[SPEAKER_00]: He peed himself a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: He went, shit, that guy's big.
[SPEAKER_00]: Goblin politics.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next time I'm leaving.
[SPEAKER_00]: The short ones are always the most dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roman actually listens to a lot of political stuff on
[SPEAKER_03]: Roblox, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's really weird.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, he's got a YouTube channel.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not like it's super active or anything, but he likes YouTube or Roblox.
[SPEAKER_06]: Trying to switch to Minecraft.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Minecraft was more my generation.